l'objet en voie de disparition en
angleterre les fameuses paille de
plastique qui ont été bannis cette
semaine on est à la veille du jour de la
terre est ici au québec on va vraiment
mettre l'accent sur ce fléau du
plastique qui polluent les la terre qui
polluent les océans et avec renault
manuguerra gagné connexion ce matin
saluera nous rejoue cette semaine
coïncidence a découverte d'une enzyme
qui peut permettre de faire dégrader le
plastique
oui et c'est cette découverte qui arrive
à un moment vraiment critique parce que
le plastique c'est un des plus gros
problèmes environnementaux qui existe en
ce moment il n'y a pas une semaine où on
a pas on va pas voir des photos de
l'animal retrouvé mort l'estomac rempli
de plastique se promenaient sur les
réseaux sociaux
on a même récemment découvert une
baleine échouée avec 29 kg de ces débris
dans son estomac 9 kg 29 kg plastique
dans son estomac c'est énorme
et en plus c'est aussi cette immense
masse de plastique océanique qu'on
retrouve au nord de l'océan pacifique
qui s'appelle le continent de plastique
on a récemment découvert que 7 7 mars
s'était rendu avec une étendue aussi
grande que celle du québec
ces gigantesques ça c'est la plus grande
mais à 9 5 autres des trucs comme ça
il ya une deuxième dans le pacifique 2
dans l'atlantique une dans l'océan
indien une dans l'océan arctique les
masses de plastique qui flottent des
baisses de plastique fait attendre comme
ça il y en a il y en a six à travers le
monde comptait recensés jusqu'à
maintenant et c'est si c'est ce qu'on
semble sortir pote cette situation le
s'imposer des restrictions comme ce qui
est arrivé à londres avec les pailles en
place en angleterre avec les pailles en
plastique cette semaine et on n'a pas le
choix d'appliquer ce genre de règlement
parce qu'on vit dans un monde où ça
coûte moins cher produire du plastique
neuf que de recycler celui qu'on a déjà
mais même si cette interdiction là ça
peut aider c'est pas ça qui va régler le
problème donc pour ce qu'il faut
encourager la communauté scientifique
pour qui des nouvelles découvertes qui
se passe pour vraiment aider
l'environnement
oui est tellement d'emballage de
suremballage et la 70eme là arrive
comment on a mis au point le composent
et ils ont bâti sur quelque chose que la
nature avait réussi avant nous parce
qu'en 2016 et des chercheurs qui ont
découvert une bactérie dans un centre de
tri de recyclage au japon et cette
bactérie est incapable de se nourrir
exclusivement de plastique donc pas tous
les types de plastiques les uns qui
s'appelle le polyéthylène
qui représente quand même 40 % du
plastique qu'on produit à chaque année
et qui entre dans la composition par
exemple des bouteilles en plastique et
en temps normal c'est ce matériau qui
sont l'aise dans la nature ça va prendre
des siècles avant de se dégrader
mais ces bactéries le produit une enzyme
qui est capable soit c'est une enzyme
sur une molécule qui accélèrent les
réactions chimiques puis qui est capable
de dégrader plastique en quelques
semaines seulement
au départ ça restait cette bactérie le
reste est juste une curiosité
scientifique parce qu'on ne peut pas
l'utiliser à grande échelle au niveau
industriel pour vraiment aider à se
débarrasser du plastique mais vu que
c'est une espèce qui est relativement
nouvelle les chercheurs ont voulu
continuer de l'étudier pour essayer de
voir si on peut améliorer le processus
c'est un peu ce qui s'est passé dans la
découverte de cette semaine me disent
que sa découverte leur intérêt par
accident oui mais ça c'est parce qu'un
des moyens qui couramment utilisé en
sciences pour comprendre comment une
enzyme une protéine ça peut fonctionner
c'est qu'ils vont soyez ajouté soyez
retirer des composés pour voir comment
ça change son mode d'action son
fonctionnement c'est ce que les
chercheurs ont fait ici mais quand ils
ont ajouté un composé organique
ils sont retrouvés avec une enzyme qui
fonctionnait beaucoup mieux qu'avant
c'est vraiment pas l'objectif initial
des chercheurs l'associant à coup de
chance poule mais sont quand même
retrouvé avec une enzyme qui
fonctionnait 20% mieux que ce qu'ils
avaient avant et que tu as même capables
de dégrader des nouveaux types de
plastiques donc ça c'est vraiment un
coup de chance inattendue
c'est sûr que l'envié mais pas encore
une solution qui est applicable à grande
échelle mais là maintenant que les
chercheurs savent qu'ils peuvent
l'améliorer mais vont continuer de
travailler là dessus pour essayer
vraiment d'en faire un outil qui va
aider à protéger l'environnement donc
éventuellement peut-être à plus de types
de plastiques
oui ça c'est difficile à dire parce que
au niveau moléculaire chaque type de
plastique une structure et des
propriétés qui le rendent unique mais ça
fait aussi que les plastiques peuvent
pas se mélanger les gens avec les autres
c'est pour ça qu'on les recycle baye
fall étrillé mais c'est ce qui demande
beaucoup de temps beaucoup d'argent et
qui l'est ce qui laisse beaucoup de
contamination qui peuvent faire que le
plastique finale recyclé moins efficace
que du plastique neuf mais cette enzyme
la 100 mètres capable de ramener les
plastiques à leurs matériaux les plus à
leur élément le plus primaire
donc ça ça pourrait nous permettre de
tous les mélanges et dangereux pour les
recycler ensemble ce qui simplifierait
beaucoup la donne et en plus ça promet
nous permettre de nous débarrasser du
plastique et danser grand îlot au milieu
de l'océan
parce qu'en ce moment même si on allait
les chercher on prépare recycler le
plastique parce qu'il est trop
endommagée par son séjour dans l'océan
pourraient être utiles à l'industrie
avec sept ans di maulo ça pourrait
vraiment changé la donne
mais là il faut pas trop miser là dessus
il faut aussi réduire notre consommation
de plastique
c'est pour ça que la réglementation qui
fait de cette semaine est important et
c'est certain il a tout ça c'est du un
coup de chance en sciences
oui effectivement lâché la science en
lâchant s'excuser moitié sa chance en
sciences c'est quelque chose qui qui est
derrière beaucoup des plus grandes
avancées scientifiques souvent les
grandes découvertes ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est fait par un scientifique
dans un laboratoire qui criait cas c'est
plus arrivé avec quelqu'un qui travaille
dans son labo pilote de couy loisirs à
c'est bizarre ça élève à faire des
nouvelles expériences pour essayer de
comprendre qu'est ce qui cloche dans ce
qu'il a devant lui
le lam le meilleur exemple de ça c'est
la découverte du premier antibiotique et
la pénicilline qui était découverte
quand des chercheurs ont remarqué que
les contenus dans lesquelles ils
faisaient pousser leurs bactéries de
toutes les bactéries avaient été et est
morte parce qu'elle va ça avait été
contaminée par un champignon
microscopique qui s'appelle le
penicillium qui lui avait produit
quelque chose qui avait tué que les
bactéries les rayons x eux aussi ont été
découverts par accident quand le
chercheur qui travaille là dessus a
réalisé que ça passe à travers les
matériaux dans son laboratoire est
l'exemple le plus drôle c'est la
découverte du viagra
initialement ce médicament l'heure été
conçu comme comme produit pour aider à
baisser la haute pression dans des
maladies cardiaques
ça marchait pas très bien mais les
chercheurs ont découvert qu'il y avait
un effet secondaire qui était de
maintenir les érections chez l'homme et
se baisse et donc c'était beaucoup plus
profitable de le vent de cette façon là
donc
l'enzyme anti plastique ça pourrait bien
s'ajouter à la liste des découvertes
scientifiques faites par coup de chance
et en même temps ça pourrait être un
grand coup de pouce pour l'environnement
on espère on espère que ça va bien
fonctionner on va parler d'ailleurs au
jour de la terre ce dimanche c'est clair
on aura plusieurs entrevues à ce sujet
là merci beaucoup et non avec les mercis
pour 20